this happened at the Stonegate
apartments right near Nellis and Sahara
8 News no reporter or co-manage oins us
live there now with more on what
witnesses say happened or Co well Sasha
witness witnesses tell us that this
happened just before 8 o'clock last
night and luckily no one was injured
some of the cars that were damaged have
been towed but others are still here you
can see the back of that BMW is
destroyed with the rear bumper taken off
now this is video sent to us by a viewer
who lives here showing the aftermath of
the crash witnesses tell us a white
pickup truck hit these cars that were
parked at the Stonegate apartments
creating basically a domino effect and
then the driver sped off
we're told around 7 cars total were
damaged as well as one of the car ports
witnesses say the white pickup truck had
no license plates and that police have
been contacted one man whose car was hit
tells us since this happened on private
property that was affected have to foot
the bill someone's gonna have to deal
with this during a time of shutdown
where in most of Las Vegas we're out of
jobs because this is a tourist City and
we don't have that we're pretty much
looking at at having to cover all
damages that witness you just heard from
has set up a GoFundMe page to help those
impacted you can find a link to that on
our web site 8 News now.com now people
who live here tell us these cars have
still not been towed because there's
fear that the damaged carport will
topple over them we reached out to the
apartment complex for an update on what
will happen next but we haven't heard
back from them yet reporting live in Las
Vegas tonight Orko mana 8 news now